All right, New Year, new expectations, new
membership code, use the code better 21.
Why?
Come on, guys, because we want a better 2021
than 2020.
Use the coupon code better 21.
All one word.
All lowercase numbers can't be lowercase,
but the letters can better 21 to get a major
discount off of the cost of a membership at
join Pakman dot com.
OK, so even though Donald Trump has been completely
missing from being the president for what
is now several months, he did post another
one of these bizarre videos on New Year's
Eve.
And this is a particularly deranged video.
I showed it to some mental health professionals
and said if this person were a patient and
came into the office making claims like these,
what would you think?
And everybody I showed it to in some version
or another said I would question whether the
patient is losing connection to reality.
We'd be thinking about whether medication
is appropriate now.
That's not a diagnosis of Trump.
It's a hypothetical about if Trump was on
your couch rather than on your TV making these
claims, what would you think?
So let's get right into it.
A very odd five minute speech posted to Trump's
Twitter on New Year's Eve. Trump not slurring
in this particular speech.
His voice does sound strange.
Let's get right into it.
In the face of great challenges this year,
Americans showed incredible grit, strength,
tenacity and resolve.
And together, we achieved truly historic victories
like nobody ever thought possible to defeat
the China virus.
We launched the largest mobilization since
World War Two.
We transformed our factories to build tens
of thousands of ventilators and millions and
millions of masks.
Virtually overnight.
Nobody thought it could be done.
We ignored the experts who demanded open borders,
and we shut down travel from China and Europe
to protect our citizens.
And we built the wall.
So this is Trump's completely delusional revisionist
history on covid.
We've been one of the biggest global failures
uncovered.
We failed on testing.
We are actively failing on vaccination, which
we'll get to tomorrow.
But this isn't new information.
We have the seventh highest per capita cases
in the world.
We have the 12th highest per capita death
rate in the world, excluding a couple of tiny
territories like San Marino and Andorra, if
we include them were 14th highest.
I won't bore you with more of that.
You're likely as sick of hearing about those
numbers as I am.
And then just last thing, Trump casually says
we built the wall.
No wall was built.
The promise was a wall across the entire border.
By January 20th.
There's two weeks left.
There's no wall.
Let's keep going.
We pioneered groundbreaking new therapies
and treatments and we saved millions of American
lives over and over again.
We were told it would be impossible to deliver
a vaccine by the end of the year.
All of the experts said absolutely unthinkable.
Trump is exaggerating.
It can't happen.
And we did it long before the end of the year.
They said it would take a medical miracle,
and that's exactly what it is.
Years from now, they'll be talking about it.
They'll be talking about this great, great
thing that we did with the vaccines.
A truly unprecedented, amazing medical miracle.
Normally developing a vaccine takes up to
ten years thanks to Operation Warp Speed.
We developed a vaccine in just nine months.
Now the lies there are a bit more nuanced.
No one said this is a straw man.
No one said you can't do a vaccine by the
end of the year.
And in fact, you can go back to my shows in
late April and early May.
And I showed you sober projections.
One was, I believe, from Goldman Sachs, which
I think what you want about them when it comes
to these these timelines, they've been pretty
good.
And they said we expect an emergency use vaccine
sometime in November and health care vaccinations
could start at the end of November or early
December.
That ended up being the case.
So it's not nobody was saying we'd have a
vaccine this year.
But remember that Trump promised us a hundred
million doses by the end of 2020.
That failed.
He then definitely promised us twenty million
vaccinated by the end of 2020.
We are only now getting to the first four
and a half, five million doses, first dose
given.
Remember, you need two doses.
So Operation Warp Speed has fallen about 90
percent short of what was promised.
And that's the bottom line fact.
And then here Trump really gets even more
delusional.
We've already begun a nationwide vaccination
program and we're sending the vaccine all
over the world.
The world will benefit, will benefit, and
everybody's calling to thank me.
We know of no calls from world leaders thanking
Trump zero.
We know of zero calls, but that's not.
Really, the big part to talk about, Trump
says we're sending the vaccine all over the
world, that's about five layers of lies.
First, many of the vaccines have nothing to
do with Operation Warp Speed.
It's pharmaceutical companies that are sending
the vaccine all over the world.
No to Trump turned down 100 million doses
of the Pfizer vaccine in late July.
So the 100 million doses were then sold by
Pfizer to other countries.
We're not sending them.
We turned them down.
So Pfizer sold them to somebody else.
We could have had them.
Trump said no.
And now Pfizer has figured out that other
countries want them and they're sending them
elsewhere.
So just wrong on four or five different levels.
Let's keep going.
Trump then singing his praises and grading
himself.
We will end the pandemic once and for all.
This is one of the most extraordinary scientific,
industrial and medical feats in history.
Everybody has it is that that's what they're
marketed down as.
And we can never let people forget where it
came from and how it came.
Trump continues to be obsessed with his marks,
as he calls them, says that the world has
marked this down as a major success.
Of course, we have the Pfizer Bion tech vaccine
thanks to Turkish immigrants in Germany.
The Moderna vaccine overseen by Israeli born
chief medical officer touchbacks and French
businessman CEO Stephane Bunzl, who's the
CEO of Moderna.
And we have the Oxford vaccine developed in
Oxford, England, starting to be approved.
What is Trump talking about?
Skipping ahead a little bit here.
Trump touts his great economy and then he
goes into some real whoppers about the GDP,
which we've been warning you about for a while.
Our economy is growing at the most rapid rate
ever recorded, thirty three point four percent
last quarter and much faster than the nations
of Europe.
Nobody can compete with us.
This one is just sad.
We had rapid GDP growth in the third quarter
after record GDP loss in the second quarter.
If you have 10 apples and a takeaway seven
and then give you six back and brag about
how no one's ever given you more apples than
me, I'm kind of an idiot, right?
Nobody would fall for that.
But people are falling for the equivalent
story that Donald Trump is telling.
And of course, it's similar with Europe.
Europe is seeing slower GDP growth because
they had less GDP decline to begin with, understand
it.
So it's a total farce.
And Donald Trump rapidly approaching his last
and final public appearances tonight in Georgia
in support of the two Republican candidate
candidates there.
I'll be covering it live.
I hope you'll join me on YouTube, twitch and
or Facebook.
You can stream it on all three at once if
you want, starting about eight thirty p.m.
Eastern Time tonight.